allergy interaction checking Pharmacy
benefit eligibility checking formulary
compliance
a medication history reporting followed
by a prescription routing to a retail
pharmacy or a mail order pharmacy so
those are the inherent functions that
will be the part of the research efforts
current knowledge
we have some excellent studies on
personal health records cost benefit
analysis of Vista the VA system
a return on investment of Telehealth
systems return on investment for cpoe or
computerized physician order entry
even the cost of interconnecting health
and information exchanges but by and
large many times policy makers have to
rely on estimates that are based on
expert opinion rather than evidence and
in some of the when we talk about Delphi
studies in a minute but in some of the
Delphi studies the earlier ones policy
makers and Latin America and various
other places will rely on expert opinion
uh to make certain decisions and so
where there isn't uh evidence you can't
do for certain of these things
randomized clinical controls so example
you can't do a randomized blind clinical
trial on using epic versus Cerner and
and that was noted in a recent piece of
uh literature which I think I'll add to
my dissertation documents but so it
really is a lot of expert opinion
involved in this one question I always
have is who are the experts and we'll
get to that uh much of the related
research doesn't identify all the
stakeholders noted I said earlier that
most of the costs are born by the
clinicians currently and most of the
benefits are in order to pay ours well
obviously the vendors are stakeholders
the vendors have weighed in pretty large
and some of the issues we have with
health I.T and meaningful use other
stakeholders include you know Pharmacy
benefit managers and the equivalent
group in the UK
and society as a whole and I think when
we say pay ours it could mean a
government pay or a commercial pair like
some of the current research tries to
address return on investment in the
context of a specific setting a medical
group or hospital
but having a pretty strong Finance and
Accounting background I can tell you
that this is not really transportable
anywhere and it really is just one
specific Medical Group and one specific
thing because what someone pays to
purchase a particular uh technology and
the update maintenance could vary based
upon a number of things
also in e-prescribing we have the notion
that sometimes it's part of a module of
computerized with a shorter entry so the
knowledge base and the unmet need
without additional research I think it's
difficult for payers integrated Liberty
systems legislature legislators and
those who influence public policy to
make rational decisions about the use of
certain health information Technologies
and so and how to go about determining
how to set and align incentives and why
is this important today well as the
system moves from payment for fee for
service to paying for quality and cost
Effectiveness a lot of the systems are
changing and in the context of those
changing systems a lot of the payment
mechanisms are being revised for example
in an ACO or a CCO here in Oregon uh you
might be incentivizing certain
clinicians to manage a diabetic patient
a COPD patient like and the use of
informatics Tools in that could be
important and often is the long-term
goal here is a set of framework that
will assist in the development of these
incentives and payment mechanisms
in the context of Health I.T and focus
on these applicable quality benefit cost
Financial considerations and
the reason is that you can spot this in
some of the literature even the
scientific literature it is critical to
align risk and reward for health I.T
investment and it's one of the problems
with meaningful use in the sense that
it's not really it's not paying for
everything it's not aligning all the
risk and reward it's just a payment for
having the technology that does this and
going forward if it's going to be
actually used in the context of
increasing the quality of care there
needs to be incentives for doing that
and both on the time of process and
outcomes measures
so e-prescribing how does it work
the clinician is essentially the client
the client signs into the e-prescribing
system by communicating with the server
and the system is typically prescribing
software or as I noted a bit earlier it
could be a module of a cpoe system
the sign-on process maintains the
security of the system
the clinician would need to approve his
or her identity and verify legal
prescribing permission and whether I
look at those systems in the United
States and the UK it's just different
but there's a similarity to actually how
they go about doing that the clinician
inputs the patient's name reviews the
current data about the patient including
current past medication clinician
selects the medication to be prescribed
and the clinician signs the prescription
and transmits it now in some places for
example in the UK the this will happen
if the patient mentioned a pharmacy but
if the patient didn't they would get a
script with a barcode and even though
they don't have the same thing as
Pharmacy benefit managers in the same
way in the UK they sort of have a
similar system where a group decides
what the equivalent of the amount that
patient might pay it might not be called
a copay or deductible as it is here but
actually uh there it may be based on age
and how much your coverage is so it's a
very similar system
the clinician's signature is a digital
signature it's verified through public
key cryptography digital signatures are
made with a private key and the
verification is with a public key and
this seems to be similar throughout the
systems that I've studied throughout the
world and there's this notion of RX hub
and RX Hub is really the facilitator in
this process and so the e-prescribing
system connects with RX hub
and you'll see up top there it talks
about
the pbm's pharmacy benefit managers or
health plans so many of the health plans
contract with pvms or have pbms but this
determines whether the patient's
eligible for a particular payer and the
patient's co-payment or deductible so
the important part there
is that the physician doesn't have to
make or it's office an oral query about
a particular thing and this could deal
with
what tier of the formula the drugs on
how high the copay is or whether it's
covered or not or whether you have to do
something else to get off formulary
and then this can be presented meaning
the formula are applicable to the
patient and their medication SG
presented to the provider point of care
and the patient's preferred Pharmacy can
be verified so in real life going to my
particular clinician who the only thing
he has that's electronic is he
prescribing as a paper records right
outside when you walk in his office you
can see how simply he does it and he
asks you what pharmacy do you want and
if you tell him then it appears assuming
you have gotten to the point where they
figured you're eligible and the like at
your Pharmacy your script so the
communications accomplished through
transmission control protocol Internet
Protocol
and the data is encrypted and in the
United States if Medicare Part D is is
involved
and the user wants qualify for
Meaningful use she has to use the
National Council for prescription drug
programs Scripts
with one exception if it's a situation
where they're all part of one illegal
entity
the pharmacy and the providers then they
can use hl7
uh the specific aims for my work are to
identify what models are presently
applicable in the area of Health I.T
particularly e-prescribing which
identify stakeholders quality benefits
costs and financial effects and they're
all over the board
to develop a way to identify the most
important quality benefit costs and
financial effects and a prioritize them
because I think it's important when
legislators or payers look at these
types of things what do the stakeholders
think are more important to them about
these particular
categories to provide an expression of
what I learned about quality benefit
cost and financial effects in a
framework
and then here's an example
it's very hard finding an example of
e-prescribing this you can kind of get
your hands around I'm not saying I get
my answer on this but the best one I
found
was from the UK and see this thing
called a PPA that's a prescription
pricing Authority that's similar to our
pbms so that processes the payment for
the prescriptions so the GP
sees the patient and uh he or she
the patient either says yes I want ABC
Pharmacy or not so it's very similar in
many respects to the United States
system so
this goes through the store here that's
considered our Pharmacy
so our Pharmacy so what happens
essentially is
electronically the GP would
prescribe something the PPA the
prescription pricing Authority processes
payment and determines uh eligibility
and the like and what uh what the copay
might be uh the the pharmacy and gets
the electronic thing and the the
pharmacist can be in the pharmacy so
this just shows how the pharmacist looks
at this determines goes through the drug
drug and Allergy things and the like and
how that's going to work and then
essentially the patient either gets
a script in this case with a barcode if
he or she hasn't mentioned the store the
pharmacy they want to go to or the it
just appears at the store once this
happens and in the UK they're aren't a
lot of the same coverage issues it's
mortal based fund age and whether you're
covered but
um
that's a simplified version the Salford
model
uh so the research question here is for
implementing health information
Technologies such as informatics
Technologies like heat prescribing can
we identify the applicable stakeholders
and the attendant quality benefit costs
and financial effects and can we
prioritize these ladders so we can have
a framework that can be used by payers
integrated Delivery Systems and
legislators that will assist them in the
development of these payment mechanisms
and incentives and so why this is timely
is because I mentioned earlier a lot of
these payment mechanisms are evolving
under payment for quality and cost
effectiveness
so in that regard I've selected the
Delphi method
as a way to answer the research question
so you'll see in the upper right corner
three Delphi oracles uh
this is and you'll see below that the
Rand Corporation in Santa Monica I've
been to the Rand Corporation it's quite
an impressive Place uh this originated
in a series of studies at the Rand
Corporation conducted in the 50s
I've read probably 50 or 60 Delphi
studies and Rand studies it's incredibly
interesting but it's a technique to
obtain the most reliable consensus of a
group of experts and if ever there was a
project to apply the Delphi method it's
this one because as you look at the
current research is literally all over
the board there's no standard framework
or model allows a group of experts to
address a complex problem
you get feedback from the individual
contributions of information on
knowledge and it's done with a series of
questionnaires and generally two or more
rounds
um
my friends at Wikipedia which were not
supposed to say so it's not on my slide
deck so it's been used to it as a tool
to implement multi-stakeholder
approaches for participative
participatory policy making in
developing countries
so you can see when uh and we probably
should use it in the United States
because many of our policy making
doesn't seem to be based on any evidence
either but
um at least to make some decisions on a
major scale in countries based on what
some experts in there's but all sorts of
studies and 40s and 50s about making
bombs and the various things through the
Rand Corporation technique anyway it's a
form of control feedback there's no
direct confrontation of experts and it's
an anonymous so uh everybody when
they're going through the process will
know who the other people are
and oftentimes they don't know who they
are at the end of the research this
seems like this really wouldn't work for
a PhD dissertation where you think you
have 30 experts around the world and you
don't mention who they are so we'll
probably
mention that later
so here's an application of the Delphi
method outside of healthcare
a uh in the mid 80s a survey was made of
Chief Information Systems op managers of
what they thought the most critical
information management systems issues
were and a consensus of their importance
the data was collected in three rounds
of surveys and they ranked ordered the
top 10 issues so I don't know whether
we'll be limiting it to 10 issues for
each
stakeholder in terms of quality benefit
cost Etc but the idea is sewing to rank
order them in some form what do they
view most important now one of the
reasons for this of course would be
if you're setting a payment mechanism or
an incentive system it's helpful to know
what a particular stakeholder that might
be incentivized is going to think is
most important to them because many
times things don't always have to be
Financial although they have Financial
repercussions and so it may be that any
particular
country or state or ACO model may be
different but knowing what a panel of
experts think is most important will be
helpful in that regard and This lends
itself later to a ton of potential
qualitative research as you can see in
the sense that uh what are they think in
Pennsylvania about this some Market or
whatever compared to somewhere else
an example of an application of the
Delphi method in healthcare
uh this I thought was kind of
interesting because
there was a research project working on
cost-benefit analysis of EHR by primary
care physicians and ambulatory setting
and so what did they do when they
couldn't find data on cost and benefit
they used modified Delphi technique all
right so they came up with a consensus
here's only a seven member expert panel
and basically they're guessing that
adverse drug events would be reduced by
approximately 34 percent so a range of
10 to 70 70 percent and alternative drug
suggestion reminders would say 15
ranging from five to twenty five percent
so they didn't have so you can just
think about this we're at the stage
where you can't even do it's a great
study but you can't do
a true cost benefit analysis without
having Delphi experts guesstimate the
number of adverse drug events and
percentages and Alternate drugs
suggestion reminders
this is not going to be
terribly persuasive to many uh
government-led people legislators and
health plans so I think that the idea of
having in this case we're talking about
30 and looking at different systems is
is probably more robust but this happens
oftentimes because the the data is not
available so when people say
we don't think ehrs pan out or whatever
it is and the like many times uh their
guesstimates involved and what happens
so what are the methods
well still continue literature and
internet search to identify existing
models uh research what are the most
important quality benefit cost Financial
consideration so I can start with an
idea of what they are for the Delphi
experts pre-owned merrily I've mentioned
here patients uh providers but if you're
being Global it's probably going to be
providers slash prescribers they're
going to have a different sense of
someone who can't prescribe
um payers and payers are also going to
be governmental entities acos ccos and
like depending upon the country in the
market
and the pharmacy and the youth lot of
the UK research they refer to them as
the dispensers
so I certainly have to spend a little
more time figuring out you know is it
three or four things to put us what the
Senate is because I don't want the folks
if there were folks in Ireland to not
as I said earlier these are the
prescription pricing authorities at
least that's the similar thing in the UK
and then um the possibility of including
vendors
uh second method part of the methods is
enlisting a panel of global experts who
could be stakeholders researchers noted
authorities and others and present them
with the results of the initial research
and certain questions and what we'll
call an online survey or questionnaire
and I'm uh I'm kind of trying to figure
out redcap now though I just you folks
which will help facilitate the
identifying additional stakeholders
prioritizing the quality benefits cost
effective Financial effects of Health
I.T particularly informatics
Technologies he prescribing the idea
here being that
some of the Delphi methods used four
different panels of experts depending
upon who they are what their background
is
it seems to me that if you're a
physician take Dr Hurst for example an
educator a researcher and potentially a
patient you fit in a lot of the boxes
okay so I can't just say all right well
I just want academics on one panel
clinicians on another panel or
politicians on some panel you can take
some of the politicians that are
positioned so the idea is instead of
having four different tracks of people
to have approximately 30 that have maybe
of all yolks maybe some would be Patient
Advocates but there are a number of
professors or Patient Advocates
asking the experts to prioritize the
quality benefits the cost of financial
effects from the perspective of the
individual stakeholder so if they're
looking at the stakeholder being a
patient the expert would look from their
perspective as a patient what were the
most important things to them to provide
their perspective from
uh summarize would summarize the answers
the questions the first two rounds and
generate new questions based on the
summary
this is just a
possible idea it could be a whole poster
board of what it might look like uh
but the idea would be you could see most
of the results of the research probably
in one big post report if you put it
there
so it'd be generating a framework which
should facilitate the use of future
informatics tools so you can see you can
do this for any informatics tool and the
transition from fee for service to
payment for Quality because the payers
integrated Delivery Systems legislatures
and people influence public policy then
have a model which would assist them in
these incentives and payment mechanisms
here
after we go through three rounds
with the preliminary framework
the idea would be to forward it to
another but smaller group of Delphi
experts to ask them how useful they
think the framework might be
so you can see that these people uh
that are in this group of Delphi experts
could be more slanted to be payers
integrated Delivery Systems legislators
clinicians and the like the types of
people that would make those decisions
on you today
so what is the significance
pay or integrated leverage system
legislators like they can choose any
number of stakeholders to look at as
they're designing a system they can look
at you know certain quality benefit type
things cost adverse effects they can
include them or not include them if they
think they're important in their system
they can use their estimates they can
use other estimates of what they think
quantitatively the component is they can
decide that they want to do a return on
investment so the last uh
call up here might be a formula without
numbers and but people to come up with
what they think the return on investment
might be for their particular situation
so how are they going to allocate the
money the end result is to make better
decisions with respect to these emerging
payment systems
than ones that are now based upon my
mind guesses hopeful expectations and it
will work that's it
so what are the limitations
we only have one Health I.T informatics
technology we're using e-prescriber and
I can tell you that's difficult enough
trying to put the parameters around this
and they're over
600 e-prescribing technologies that are
part of share Scripts
so and you go to those websites and some
are gone some have been bought you know
the healthcare industry people buy and
sell things all the time
so just trying to get your handle on one
form of the technology is difficult
enough and we'll only have a response
from a limited number of global experts
although much of the research I've seen
said 12 to 14 Global Acts or experts is
enough so we're going to be more careful
and try to have around 30. and as you
can see the research is in its infancy
I'm glad that this research is starting
in the west because it really is the
Wild West in this area there isn't
really that much there that's uh it's
important but it's not as useful as it
should arguably be
so the timeline
I'm here today
defensive proposal June 13th
I'm hoping to work with Joan to figure
out the IRB submission for this and do
it this summer having reviewed a lot of
IRB issues in the past I as a lawyer I
can tell you that it's much more
difficult when you're submitting one
rather than you're just talking about
the ethical issues of a particular
project
um the first round questionnaire
hopefully that would be
um this September it would be uh this
would be like in in Adelphi world this
is called brainstorming so
I'm going to come up with what I think
some of the stakeholders should be I'm
not going to order a rank order various
benefits and quality but give them some
ideas I will probably uh
for purposes of make it better I might
if I have 10 for example
quality considerations for a provider I
wouldn't start with the same one for
every
oh each of the 30 Delphi experts am I
starting the middle of one so to mix it
up some and so I'd ask them to put
whatever additional stakeholders they
wanted
and to set their own priorities then in
round two which I would anticipate
November 2014.
this is what is known in the Delphi
world as true narrowing
so you ask them to I summarize the
result of the first questionnaire
you asked the Delphi experts to
reconsider their prioritization of the
various components from the benefit of
each stakeholder and so you try to get
them to narrow down what they think and
of course at this round they will now
see seeing stakeholders potentially they
wouldn't have seen and quality cost
benefits they wouldn't have seen based
upon hopefully the results of others
then we go to round three uh anticipate
January 2015. maybe summarizing the
results of the second questionnaire
noting for the Delphi experts that
there's their last chance to reach a
consensus
uh and for them to reconsider their
prioritization and this is why you know
anonymity is important
so if
I said in the
question here
uh noted who had said what
and since Blackford Middleton on my
committees one of the leading
authorities in the world on some of this
season I said he ranked this this and
this that could affect what somebody
else thought so the idea is that they'll
see that maybe in this case 17 out of 30
people thought this would be right
recorded one but they want to know who
those people are and with that then
changed there so
the last part
of uh this this aspect of the Delphi
study can be known as
doesn't always have to be but known as
the statistical group response so that
this study may be finished in round
three and there may not be anything that
you can get meaningful from a
statistical standpoint and we may be
done with that and we may put in a
framework and then move forward on the
other hand
there's a possibility of looking at what
are the mean ratings of the top issues
are significant different from one
another could it be a bonferoni there's
a possibility of looking at cap iterator
things with who rated what way and the
beautiful thing about a
study like this is you don't decide that
in advance
you'll wait until you see what the date
is you're just open to the way you might
be able to analyze it
so we come up from this with a draft
framework this would be circulated to
the New Delphi experts I'm hoping that
would be March 2015.
and it'd be a determination by the New
Delphi Experts of
what the framework might be useful and
how useful for payers integrated Liberty
systems legislators and those who
influence public policy
in developing these payment mechanisms
and setting and aligning incentives for
various stakeholders
so then I would propose to summarize the
right research and Pen the dissertation
between April and May 2015.
and defend the dissertation
in June 2000
2015 one year from today or this month
so with that I'd like to acknowledge my
committee
Dr Ash who's been my advisor mentor and
has given me incredible ideas
Dr Fletcher who has certainly had an
interesting Dimension from a computer
science aspect helping me to understand
better the technical aspects of this
uh
Dr hunsicker Who I his Dimension has
been incredibly helpful and challenging
me to better understand the usefulness
of this how it fit in and including some
of the courses in his group and Dr
Middleton who is one of the leading
authorities in this area that you know
off the top of his head sends me three
articles you know and or four articles I
had a number of the articles but I
didn't catch the exact point until he
told me where it was in the article and
then it really created some great Focus
uh D mice of course uh Jim's group the
division of management a lot of the
courses that I have privilege to take in
that group have added to my knowledge
base the National Library of Medicine of
course for my funding in my Law Firm for
letting me print thousands of documents
things well on the screen and I do mean
thousands of pages of documents and
providing a place where I can do this
stuff late at night where the lights are
on uh with that I'd be happy to take any
questions since it's 11 39.
two questions
um actually what's really more common
and it's kind of a semantic Point
um
you you
when you talk about the purpose
um you know you talk the purpose the
first purpose you give is to identify
and prioritize dot dot dot and then your
sub purpose is to develop develop and
evaluate a framework I actually think
really your purpose is that sub purpose
um okay and that what you really want to
do is to develop and evaluate a
framework and and that's actually the
fact that I was a little worried as you
were starting to talk that you were
going to focus more you know because one
of the contributions of a PhD
dissertation is is new methods and and
techniques you know as opposed to just
having to find it so I think it's
important to kind of play up the model
part of it my question then gets to the
model
um
I I don't I don't have a real sense for
what this model is going to look like I
mean maybe one thing you could have done
was sort of that now that you can
predict what's going to come out of your
process but you know to put up a slide
that would have an example is this say a
quantitative model that like policy
makers will be able to plug things into
the parameters and kind of come up with
their own evaluation
um or is it more of a kind of conceptual
model with boxes and arrows and things
like that it's a model won't be any
arrows but um it's a model
where um
somebody would see
the perception of the experts who all
the stakeholders might be and then under
say quality benefit they would have a
rank order
of what the experts thought the top
quality and benefits were and then
similarly uh with respect to either
Financial facts or cost now here's an
example and I don't want to honestly
authors but somebody's made a stab at
this in a much different way list of
potential ER implementation ongoing
expenses and
um this uh is uh it's a eight and a half
by 14 instead of just by 40 betas here
and they list each expense in a category
and they've taken the time
to uh in my view unfortunately figure
out
whatever cost center in a hospital when
affected and this made me think that
and I didn't say it's right it's I don't
really want to do a project there's
going to be a definition around what you
can call a quality or cost benefit so a
a benefit can be it simplifies a process
but a benefit can't be I'll get
reimbursed more in the United States
system because I didn't I do a calling
okay so this thing here goes through all
these cost centers and how you can
capture the expense
to get um paid in some model and to me
that's a reimbursement system and I want
to get away from a reimbursement system
and I want to get to a system where some
like let's say your
um an ACL or a CCO you can look at this
and say
all right these these stakeholders are
benefiting in this order I'm going to
set a new model because there's a lot of
new models on the drawing board now and
how can I invest incentivize some of
these people what is most meaningful to
them for example uh and I took this out
but I had a consumer health informatics
example so a lot of people think today
that we ought to be in a
patient-centered world
incentivizing patients
to have and use certain informatics
tools on a phone okay so
we have issues like and this would only
time judgment should relate this but
under some models and some of the legal
systems which is why I think my
background's helpful you can't
necessarily just give somebody a cell
phone if it acts as a cell phone you can
give them because it can be an
inducement for them being part choosing
your delivery system but on the other
hand you could give them a cell phone
that only
interacted with their Healthcare now a
person with uses much all right those
are the types of things if somebody said
I want to have a robust uh system of
incentives over it and this is not in
this project but you can see where this
is going so how can you incentivize
patients to better manage their health
and in that process and this would be
across the board so the framework itself
somebody could say Okay
um
so you're you're gonna I mean I
understand that and you know I know that
you know in the cost Effectiveness world
and literature that you know people are
encouraged well you have to identify the
perspective that you're taking and
people are typically encouraged to sort
of take the societal perspective but I
guess my is this going to be a a model
that say a policy person can
um you know there's a bunch of
parameters in the model and they can
plug in things and and then I guess my
question would be
what a possible I know you can't do
everything of dissertation but would it
possible aspect of this work being to
somehow validate
um whatever kind of financial model or
whatever well the initial ballot that's
why we have the smaller group of Delphi
experts at the end so they can say they
think this tool be useful where this
eventually goes my understanding was
that if you pick a dissertation top you
should pick one where there's tons of
potential research going forward okay so
in this particular situation I can see
and also I have not been blind to the
many presentations around here about how
hard it is to get funding okay and I
don't have those same problems okay so I
see a situation where I go to one of the
foundations that as a health plan was a
spin-off of a health plan or something
they're trying to look at what these
models are anyway and what they can do
so I might take exactly what you said
all right and maybe they might say given
their parameters and what they're doing
in their patient population what sort of
priority incentives should they develop
given the analytics of what they have
that'd be a different research project I
mean uh on the other hand you may
those organizations May
um be more interesting you know like in
whatever grants whether it's an NIH
Grant or a foundation Grant you know
it's always good to have as much
preliminary work as you can so I don't
know I'm just saying giving some thought
to
um you know whether you should whether
you're District rotation would have some
examples of the supplied so that future
people funding your research it would
also be a better dissertation product
would have some component of trying to
somehow I know you could never
completely validate it but
um in all facets but but I think that'd
be fantastic if it was possible I just
don't know how much I would go in to say
Regents or cambia and say even though I
know the president and I'd say and he's
a friend of mine I'd say well Mark I'd
like to like test this out on you okay
but that would mean they would have to
help design a system based on this and
he'd probably say well I'm paying people
hundreds of millions of dollars in
comparious other things but but they
might take it and look at it I'm sure
they would at some point and and as they
start to recalibrate or look at
something decide them but I don't know
how I could actually beta test something
like that but I'd love to do it in fact
um I could see a situation
where uh you might go in
qualitative research project initially
to go into a group
and a lot of times they're coming up
with new products or they're looking at
different like I can see a pilot project
under the CMS Innovation group
saying let's look at this particular set
of issues and see whether these
incentives are going to work better or
not and then put that people put that in
this particular thing partnering with
some group for a pilot that'd be
fantastic or I I won't dwell on this but
you know maybe there are some you know
papers that have been published that
have
um have this kind of data you know that
you could just
um put in I I I'll just leave it at you
know I I think it would be nice if if
this is going to be a quantitative model
it would be nice if there were some sort
of at least pilot investigation of the
quantitative
robustness of it well remember that one
study that I imagined that they had to
go back to Delphi experts so if you can
find it you would be taking guesses on
guesses and adding them to guesses but
weekend visit
um I'm I'm open to it I like the idea uh
I just don't I don't see the first of
all there's a difficult enough time uh
that payers and others are having the
transition from fee for service to pay
for quality and cost effect on us to
begin with I mean before I came over
here I was talking to somebody in
Illinois about a specific model that
involved this kind of stuff okay but
they're way back here they want to get
here okay I need to help them to work
with them but those are excellent
comments though bill I maybe we should
sit down I'd love to be able to do that
I haven't that's why I found some of
these dealt by methods and other studies
because I don't want to project
something
I don't want to guess how the experts
guess on guesses is what I'm saying but
any other thoughts jump
um just to follow up on that maybe you
could use your second Delphi expert
group to give you some examples that you
could then pursue at least you had if
you had time or pursue after
yeah I'm sure we'll be talking about all
of this so absolutely and I've got a lot
of good ideas from you Jim and uh Justin
and blackbird so absolutely I mean this
is a you know new to me so I'm in the
bedroom
question was
estimates and things like that how is
the Delphi method better
how is what you're doing better than
what's been done in the past
well no one's done this exact thing
and uh in some of the studies that seven
experts
I think you're I think there's a
a point at which
uh you don't need any more experts so I
don't need 100 experts but I think 25 or
30 is better than seven
I think that uh having global experts
so is also better because it's not just
one Healthcare System
because as I go around the world and I
know Bill does this also a lot of the
issues are the same
I mean the reimbursement systems might
be a little different but
people are always looking at whether
they think the value of some of these
informatics tools outweigh the cost
uh it doesn't appear that we can take
the same approach that the banking
industry did although I think it would
make more sense they they didn't do an
Roi from what I understand on ATMs
they just decided that you know somebody
developed this this looked like it was
the best thing since sliced bread and
people would demand it and it would make
sense and it'd be more cost effective in
their view okay and they didn't know and
the there are millions of ATMs so I
think over time people will think that
informatics Technologies uh they'll look
back and go I can't believe we even
guessed what they are but we see this
all the time I mean you're on the same
list they're buying it though where
people are questioning you saw the one
that they had a picture of the toilet
but no I mean that like comparing you
know huh
you know I I actually get that in a
digest I don't look at individual
messages because I don't have time to
read brass couples since Scott
Silverstein's rants It generally is
those two but my point is this that
there's a whole set of discussion about
so about paper records okay so I think
that that discussion can end up being in
a number of areas and so I think people
are going to view be prescribing because
of the handwriting you know issues and
being more ubiquitous and they're going
to view that as a better framework for
some other model that's dropped into it
in the future
um
kind of a question more of a comment
and what year what do you have on the
board for a friend
and it reminds me a lot of the balanced
scorecard protector Frink
so you're going towards that double
model
and when they developed that they
actually did kind of adult-like process
but then they brought like five or six
enthusiastic people that were interested
we put them in a room in San Jose for
three days
that's from the balance Court card came
from was that 3D effort
have you considered rather than doing a
verbal just you know go to Davos and
have all the experts come there Manuka
well that's why I was thinking
my house is my only only has four
bedrooms I can't have all of them come
uh Manuka is quite it's quite reasonable
it's a conference you can talk to Jonah
that's where a lot of Jones create ideas
have percolated and gun support
well people get funding to go to some
these people are going to be from all
over the world
whoever the
you might you might just take a small
group I know that there's a funny
interview I try and get the group to
work through it and then it's not just
you it's a group of people okay that's
that's a good idea I can visit with Joe
I don't I think that uh I'm trying to
make sure as best as possible this thing
is in United states-centric because I um
I just don't think we have it right here
the whole thing and I think that so if
my group was International okay I think
it lends itself to much that's why
painstakingly went through the UK system
and tried to match up what a pharmacy
benefit now it actually was because
Justin forced me to do something else
that if he hadn't forced me to do it I
wouldn't have gotten at this other point
so that was good for that but
um
I think that's a great idea I'll talk to
Joan about it I do think I don't want a
uh
I think the credibility of this is much
greater if it's not a bunch of people
just from the United States right okay
because I know I've got to figure out a
way to tell them don't tell me a benefit
is more reimbursement so if I hear that
one more time having been a Synergy for
35 years but however maximize that's
great but all that does is increase the
percentage of the gross national product
of the healthcare and we're in a current
situation where you know if you've been
following some of these from a friend of
mine spent a hundred thousand dollars a
year under Obamacare on drugs because of
the way the exchange is and uh I
personally think that everybody should
have access to Quality Health Care now
we don't have that now so if we don't
come this is a chance at least in our
view this is a chance
for us to transform a system based on
payment mechanisms when we are working
through that and I think that the nla
I'm spending a ton of money for me to
try to do something and if I could make
a a framework or a basis for people to
think about this so sometimes they're
just thinking about this on the Fly I
got some the other day it's a from a
health plan it was a page cut out of
their tornado of their book about how
they're going to look at this set of
models I can't go through well the
thought they've had in this is not great
okay so even if they don't think this
much about this at least having this to
look at this and to think about this I
think would be helpful any other
questions I'm asking is do you have your
question already
okay I'm sorry I'm not trying to oh no
no I mean
about
trying to do a pre-test and a
questionnaire before you send a theater
the reason I'm suggesting that is just
an IRB
approves it and if you change it you've
got to accept it back to the RB
and then I could miss the time frame
that well I think that um
I think that
isn't necessary here for the following
reason one I'm going to this is good
it's a good thought I think that uh
I'm asking people
they're the Delphi experts to come up
with additional stakeholders the one way
that I pre-test it would be to send it
to Delphi experts anyway and have them
give me more stakeholders okay so I
think that this is part of and at least
in Delphi the what they call the
brainstorming exercise and so I think
that is part of the research the
brainstorming exercise
any other thoughts yes I got a couple of
questions
since I'm sort of stuck on one question
uh I'll ask it again so I'm looking at
your slide 25 don't don't go back just
keep it on this window and that that's
the research question
which says that uh can the applicable
stakeholders be identified in the
attendant qualities benefit costs and
financial issues be identified and
prioritized to create a framework
that can be used by a bunch of people to
influence public policy that will system
the development of payment mechanisms
and incentives so this
that appears to be a framework so if I'm
uh if I'm
Mark ganza candy how am I going to use
this to determine how I'm going to
either incentivize uh Farm uh docs to to
use this technology or how I'm going to
compensate your life what's what's the
Practical step that happens after you've
develop this framework
all right so let's take e-prescribing
because that's what we're talking about
um but you could take anything they
think like that PDA or the digital
device with
patient information on so
they decide that they want to do a
better job of aligning incentives in a
system and they decide that one of the
things that's important
in their view is e-prescribing because
it'll do these various things
so in looking at how they pay today
most of the time it's a fee for service
model they have some
more devout models
they might look and say all right
maybe the patient is incentivized to go
to a
dispenser I mean a provider that has he
prescribing
so maybe their co-payment is lower if
that's the case on their drugs uh maybe
they're looking at the provider
and maybe the provider the nature of the
provider maybe over time you have to be
a provider that has e-prescribing
because they've looked at the benefits
and they're this great looking at the
costs they may say
well the costs are too high for some
providers based upon this allocation of
cost maybe we as a health plan should do
something to defray the cost in a
particular informatics any number of
things like that and does this framework
get reduced to an algorithm or is it a
set of questions that the payer
looks at and tries in some
not I mean I can't imagine that this is
totally deterministic yeah in some way
to
come up with what works from the
business I think a payor could develop
their own algorithm from this given
their specific types of providers and
data and their patient population if
they wanted to
that's possible but this would not be
the algorithm itself actually I thought
about that something a little more
philosophical question so Michael Porter
and his recent writings on Health Care
is advocating that the true metric is
his value and he defines value as
outcomes that matter to the patient
the ratio of outcomes that matter to the
patient to the cost of whatever it is
you're doing
or in other words he's saying that the
central point of value is is the
patient-centric part of it so how does
that factor in here are the spot on that
so if looking at
in this case the patient is on the first
line so
the uh what is important to the patient
the dealt by experts are supposed to be
putting themselves in the position of
the patient and thinking what are any of
those
people patients I mean I guess we're all
patients well that's exactly the point
all right now as somebody said in some
recent literature we either are patients
or we will be patients sometime and
somebody then said Well if you get
killed by a bomb or something you you
may skip the patient thing but most
people will be patient so most people
have been patients at some point in time
so the Delphi experts would look at in
in Porter's example what are the types
of things that they think putting
themselves in the position of a patient
are most valuable to them all right they
would also look at what the costs
associated with that patient would be or
the cost it's not about putting in a
specific number because the other
research shows the numbers are all
across the board so that works well in
looking at my example of the PDA so if
you were going up and if somebody felt
that I want to be able to access my
information about my Pharmaceuticals
that I take or drug interactions or my
lab tests
this may be one of the greatest things
of value to a particular patient it may
be the ability to easily access
something from a phone if that's the
case then
what are the costs associated with
making that informatics technology
available to that patient this sets a
framework for looking at what those
issues so it's spot on if it's ready I
think it's a great example
yeah I
I mean I I understand all that I think
that that um
value value to the patient is not
necessarily the same as value to the
payer and and uh and
if we want to ensure that value to the
patient is the
is what wins in the long run
I mean I don't know maybe that's out of
scope here but I I like the ideas first
of all
um most health plans we're talking about
commercial health plan or in the
business of selling policies
so and making money and making money or
shareholders for well if they're for
profits yeah and the other ones I don't
know why they're making money for I
guess to but anyway
your friend takes salaries correct okay
but so oh comment on this more than a
million dollars but
um so here though this is important
because if you're a health plan
your goal May well be to maximize your
value may be different and it may be
more monetary but still quality so you
don't get sued but if you're looking at
how you're going to do that this is why
I think the informatics for all the
patient center growth is right over that
you're gonna have to one uh work toward
keeping the cost of a specific patient
down the care for that patient if it's
if that patient is summaries are just
showed that if some of these learning
tools that they're done as a game for a
patient they watch it more and they
learn more things so it may be that you
have informatics tool developed as part
of a game now it's not necessarily
because the health plan feels it wants
to be magnanimous about this it's going
to be because the health plan feels that
because this has a specific value to a
patient
and the patient may use it more in the
benefit of their care it may keep our
costs down so while we might be in it to
make money it may well be we'll make
more money if the patient gives their
diabetic situation in control more
because we provided them informatics
soil self-dism so and I think this is
exactly what you've got from this kind
of framework you have it makes somebody
think about that that you can you can
align the whole idea that's an alignment
incentives is that if a Health Plan idea
is to make money and a patient wants to
be better how can you align incentives
in a monetary perspective with a
dramatic source to make that happen
stuff
or you get too far down because one of
the things that I do ask about is if
you're doing something that involves
patient values
are you including the underrepresented
minorities in the process that's a
question
how do you make sure you're throwing it
cross-section
so what's going to Define your stuff
I see that in terms of
this technology
because the digital divide
that I mean involving them in your study
are you going to have them as people
that you respond to your expertise not
if you're you're supposed to be
representing patient's shareholders why
not let's make those why not so maybe I
should have something that when we
address the experts
thing include something like don't
forget
these types of things because I can't
have a organic patient babe
I don't know I keep thinking today but
okay he necessarily represents I don't
know I don't understand
what I'm saying on the speaking Trail
but anyway but that's a good point and
I'll visit with John there's an
excellent point when I'm just saying
take a look at the father you're gonna
have to do no that that that's an
excellent point and I think you're going
to find my experiences you're looking at
about a six week turnaround
from those people and that they're good
people but there's
that's going to be an issue
okay no I I got you that
make sure that whatever that whoever the
Delta experts are that they're cognizant
of considering the values to different
people not upper middle class Professor
structural
that's a very good point
any other thoughts questions
whatever
no I know this is just his proposal so
if you guys sign off and say he's ready
you want to answer oh yeah you had to
sign something right yes
oh